I know we've talked with you before
about being in bad relationships and
yeah it's impending doom when you know
you're in it and we take too long to get
out of them and yeah we've talked about
it being an emotional drive-by I know
you have to plan it I got assassinated
you really owe it see people always give
it the person that gets broken up with
they get all the sympathy I actually
think the person doing the breaking up
deserves a little bit of it alone it
doesn't feel good
we're not good at hurting people no so
one day just have to freestyle a knife
fight and just be like hey Julie I know
I've been giving you ice cream cones and
I won you that Homa Simpson doll and
then you have to drive home alone where
Julie used to be you can still kind of
smell her and you're like Who am I this
girl and who I really loved I loved her
but I want to change a little bit so I
was like you know what I'll do I'll take
her for a hike we'll go out in the
wilderness you know I mean we'll be out
nature perspective Prospectus give her
something nice we hiked in about a mile
and a half maybe two miles got to a
little Brook sad at the brook she's
thinking this is great I'm like yeah I
think we should probably call this quick
and she was so upset and then I had to
hike back out with her like now you got
to go back you know what I mean like I'm
like next to a cliff and she's been
crying and I'm like this is horrible
that's like a proposal spot yeah not
it's always the serial killers if they
look bad and it'd flip I know of a guy
he was taking his wife they were having
marital problems he was taking his wife
to the airport she was flying out for
some business conference or whatever she
gets out of the car and he said you got
everything or whatever she's like yeah I
got everything he's like him by the way
I want a divorce and then drove up
dropped it on her like that like take
that he knows me my god you can't take
that much baggage on the plane
J Ryan you guys are to my absolute
favorite comedians to my favorite people
absolutely in the world you know I love
to death listen to the crab feast one of
a podcast comes out on Tuesday and told
every Tuesday Tuesday
I just doesn't do it whatever but thank
you so much for being here thanks a but
bye thanks for having